In this case, even though coding is involved, the files are not
really interrelated, so it's fine to track each of the files separately, so
we don't need to check this one.
In this case the files will be highly interrelated.
The CSS file will define styles that refer to elements in the HTML file, so
there will likely be changes involved both files.
For example, you might have a single change that both adds an element to
the HTML file and also adds in a rule to the CSS file to position and
style that element.
For this third one,
it's probably fine to track the files separately since it's unlikely that
changes to one image will have anything to do with changes to another file.
For this last one you could sort of go either way.
In most cases, changing a single chapter won't have as much effect on the other
chapters, but if you want to make a big change like changing a character's name,
you probably want to change it across all the chapters all at once so
checking this would be reasonable too.